Emmanuel macron the leader of France has
just received an unpleasant package in
the mail he received a severed finger
from a living human being
this was sent to the official residence
of President Emmanuel macron according
to a report from the London evening
standard showed up at the Elysee Paris
Palace in Paris no note was included in
the package
the investigators then took the finger
and put it in the fridge
the regular fridge where they keep their
coffee and sandwiches and things because
they they wanted to preserve it so that
they could investigate it further if
it's not threatening at least a lot of
people are concluding this is the
evidence that whichever person mailed
this to macron is just totally crazy to
which I say how dare you how how dare
you how
closed-minded and bigoted of you to
suggest that this is evidence of someone
who's gone a little bit crazy who needs
psychiatric help you know what I call
this I call this fist affirming care